one item to consider before we get to
the interviews themselves is about the
jobs requiring autonomous system skills
while certain companies do have more
overarching titles is most common that
jobs you apply to will have much more
specific roles like motion playing
engineer controls engineer or perception
engineer as such the interviews you're
about to see will each be specific to
one type of these roles we suggest going
through each one of these as you'll see
different individuals going through
their own separate approaches to problem
solving their interview question well
the question itself might not be
specific to the role you were looking
for perhaps the interview is thinking
will boost you in your own interview